the final test is based on an authentic  1979 mission the high point of training  director sodas career as an active agent  the target was Jasper night a famous us  chess master exposed as a Soviet spy  sodas caught up with night at a military  airfield in Cuba and eliminated him  against all odds this is your objective  as well now listen carefully ica exams  aren't normally this difficult not only  was the airfield of virtual fortress he  even added additional guards sodas wants  you to fail he considers you a threat  and this way your unfortunate exit from  the program will not raise any eyebrows  he did not however factor me into the  equation if sodas can bend the rules  then so can I good luck initiate  apparently Jasper night is demand and  his girlfriend comes into the Soviet  Union and he refuses to leave until he  gets affirmation from his superiors in  Moscow the call will come through in the  restricted but otherwise unguarded  reading  hello  you